all right welcome back ivy
thank you it's nice to see you again
so lots of lots has changed in your life
since the last time we uh
we met not a lot but
i've made a lot of personal changes
um getting away just
getting away and thank god every time i
try to go back
to you know something bad happens
which kind of pushes me away again
um i don't know i've been more in touch
with mental health
programs counseling even going
anything that's gonna help me today i'm
leaving so where are you going today
i'm going to be going to a shows for
families
they have a um inpatient program
that's going to give me some housing
and make sure that i can get full
custody of my
both of my children back oh that's
awesome yeah
that's that's your dream come true right
yeah
i didn't want to leave the streets but
i'm like i got to
um but what keeps you from leaving from
not wan
why would you say that why would you say
you don't want to leave the streets
i wasn't ready to do better i don't know
i wasn't ready
i didn't think i was ready
i don't know yeah i guess i've heard
these stories so many times now
i don't know no it's like you become you
believe you believe you belong there
i couldn't i couldn't do it anymore i
couldn't
um i kept
it was just like my mom had told me you
know
it was just like i listened to her
telling me growing up
there's gonna be something telling you
that you can do it you know
and i didn't understand it i didn't
understand what she was saying
to me i'm like well we all have
willpower is that what it is
it's just gonna be okay i can do it all
by myself i can do it by myself
i just gotta stop smoking once i start
smoking then i can do this but
it's hard when the men in my life
are my weakness one of them one of my
greatest weaknesses
and the fact that both of the you know
the fathers of my children are in the
streets
i'm going to chase them and i'm going to
always be there
and it's not good either
for my sobriety and for my life
and you have other news too right yeah
i'm seven months pregnant
with a healthy happy baby
um i was smoking i was
i was um i was getting high during
the up to the third
month of this pregnancy and
when i found out i was pregnant once
again
it was a doctor's appointment
and i just i
cried i cried i cried
and i fought i got high again
i fought i had again
until i just i don't know
it's never a straight line it's always
going to be back and forth
it's not
so but where are you today so you're you
haven't smoked in a while
i haven't got high and i want to say
about two and a half going on three
months
um but man
it's been hard
it's been hard um
it's been tough i'll smoke a cigarette
every now and then
when i smoke a cigarette it's like
i get this little like vision of ecstasy
you know
and it's not pleasurable it's scary
and it's crazy how just that cigarette
can just be like
like you know maybe if i just go you
know
um so
yeah do you have any role models that
have done what you're trying to do
any friends because we talked about
somebody else i won't mention that
seemed to be on the right track but but
no longer is i
uh i was hearing good stuff about her um
but i'd seen her again in one of the
places that i
fall doing what i do
which was fall i couldn't judge her i
couldn't blame her but i looked up to
her
so that was hard for me too i was like
damn okay well let me you know she's
still beautiful
yeah beautiful girl she's still smart
and you know she's still
chased after and so i was just
you know i've seen her and
just like okay maybe i can you know dip
and dab
too so
just to anybody that's a role model to
somebody i got somebody to look up to
keep going i hope because people are
watching you
you know this is this is gonna be all on
you yeah your boyfriend can't
help you i can't help nobody can help
you we can support you
and cheer you on but yeah you're the one
that's going to have to have the courage
as i said last time
so um yeah but you're doing it
and the progress is like so it seems at
times it seems so
pointless it seems so like slow like ugh
what is this doing like you know like
what is being alone
doing like what is like staying away
from
everything really exciting i'm excited
i am the excitement of the street life
and all that like it's like it's a big
yeah
but i'm tired you're breaking a bunch of
addictions at the same time i'm tired
yeah
yeah i'm tired of waking up having to
pay
room money having to sell my body for
real money just so i can stay and get
sit and get high all day it's i'm tired
of
arguing and fighting with baby daddy i'm
tired of
social workers calling me like when are
you going to get it together like i'm
tired of being the one that
it's my i can only way myself is my
fault like
when do i give myself a break that's
what i'm tired of
um the guilt trips i'm tired of that
[ __ ]
i'm tired of it um
do you still crave yeah you do yeah it's
not gonna it's not gonna
end quickly i think it takes probably
it's not
trust me trust me
because i know d-boys and d-boys love me
and um what are d boys dog boys
um and these are your clients or the
dealers
no just dealers just dealers they're
i just know them as childhood friends or
big homies i look up to um
just to get inside your pants like
they'll you know
what you need to feel good you know
that's what i'm tired of
too
um i'm proud of myself yeah
i'm proud of you i'm proud
i am ready to have this baby
so the father of your baby
your child is your boyfriend yeah that's
good
yeah you guys have a good relationship
yeah we do
he's very supportive very
i'm scared that's one thing too i'm
scared to leave him
leaving when you go to uh to the program
[Music]
um he's not ready yet
so he's using as well that makes it hard
also you know dealing and
you know doing what he got to do what he
thinks he has to do
you know to survive every day just to
make sure i don't go out
in the streets every day you know
he's you know speaks a way to do what he
want to do just so he's not in my face
with it
i respect it and hate it at the same
time
um
but when i made that call to go
you know to go in he
he was very supportive of it
courage you found the courage
and that's the most important part you
can be smart as a whip you can be
beautiful as can be you can be whatever
you want but
courage is what's going to get you there
yeah i just hope you know
i hope he has some courage too because
i'm usually the one you know that
everybody's like oh
yeah no when i was out there
she's out there you know ain't no
telling her no you know
she's gone you know and if you leave her
and come back a couple months
you may see her in the same spot or
deeper you know
um and i
hope that when i come back home
that he's not dead or
you know
because he's such a man
i wanted to just get a highway just for
everything i don't
feel like i wasn't thinking that i was
better than him or above him
it's hard you know
so i have to go i gotta
go in because i will get high for the
sake of my love for you
and
relationships and drugs that's how they
grow
you know for you to feel that i love you
and i'm a part of you we both got to be
in the same state of mind
it feels a little better the direction
you're going in though is is the best
direction for you for the baby for
all your people that look up to you
right
so i'm doing this for my baby i'm doing
this
my first daughter too it's got to be
extra hard because you have no family
members that have done it right
you know you have a sister in prison you
got you know
it's you have no role models in your
family no
so um
what you're doing is remarkable
and i take pride in it you should
i take pride in it you should be very
proud
i do i take pride in it
the other talks that we've done this is
i think the fourth one
you were very very depressed and this
time you don't seem so depressed
but what has helped with that um
honestly mark i don't know
maybe it's just the fact that you're
doing the right thing yeah you know you
keep doing the wrong thing you you end
up yeah it seeps in and creates
depression
i can't over complicate it i can't it's
just
simply i don't
i want my baby's back
yeah you know
it feels good when i finally take a
break from the chaos
and everybody and when i'm sitting in a
room alone it's just like
here i am again it's only me you know
and signing you're up
setting yourself up for a program and
going through that is one thing but then
sticking with it for the long haul is
another
so it's not like just because you did it
means the job is over you're going to
have
you know temptations and reasons to
fall back for years so it's going to be
an ongoing battle but you're doing it
so i am
my spirit did feel a little lighter yeah
you smiled more in this video than you
have in all three
yeah um
yeah i'm like huh what would i say
i'm doing better but i mean it's still
boring
i always say i always tell people i'm
i'm one of the most boring videos on
there
my videos are quiet trust me i'm just
saying no you're not
you know you're one of the most
interesting ones i think yeah
um but i mean i've interviewed hundreds
and hundreds of
ladies and guys even that that have done
this kind of work
i thank god a lot because i only think i
can only think of you and one other
person that have
broken free of it really broken free i
mean you haven't done it yet of course
but
you're you you clearly look like you're
going i'm
trying i'm trying and it feels good
it feels good um
i've not been through
half of what these people have been
through
so and there'll still be hard things you
have to go through
you know money yeah other problems
but the key is just to stick with it
know you're doing the right thing and
you'll you'll be a role model for so
many other young ladies
and your and your boyfriend and people
that watch and
so many people my mom most definitely
someone said you know if you don't get
sober your mom's not going to get sober
i was like oh don't say
that no i think there's my mom she i
feel like she
does look up to me you know no but like
let's let's say you
you're successful and you have your
child and you keep your child and and
in two years you've done it you're
living a great life we'll do we'll do
more talks of course
but people will look at that and go wow
she can do it there's hope i can do it
for people like your mom for
girls like you for for viewers or
if you have a fault if you go back
somehow
you know in in one month or in one year
if you fall back
everyone will say oh see you can't do it
no one can do it
there's a strong argument for like no
one's done it so it must be impossible
so why even try
so i love the fact that you're trying
and doing it and
i i just see the energy from you is so
different today than it was
any of the other times we've gotten
together
you look better are you smiling more
everything's challenging about what
personality i want to go in wow
i'm just kidding um yeah
i'll be i'm not going to be far though
i'm really not going to even be far from
where i be so when you have the baby
you'll
still be in the program um i'm not sure
because i'm due in two months and the
program's two months
so whether i finish for i don't know
but two months is not a very long
program but no it's not but the fact
you've already been clean for how many
months now
two basically two that's good but
this is for housing so that um so it's
not a drug program
it's a drug program because i do
dr yeah that's my choice but
is it a silver living place yeah
that's what you can say basically so
realistic it's transitional
yeah yeah so they help with housing they
help with job searching
that's awesome stuff that i
myself struggled doing alone
i'm like if i just go in it'll be
simpler
so you call me anytime if you need
support
or if you're getting weak or whatever
thank you but um you're doing everything
right darling you're doing it all right
right now
yeah so happy to hear it
it feels good yeah
so what's really wonderful about your
story you know because
i've helped some of the other girls that
worked fig and and did this kind of work
and i bought them cars and i got them a
roof over their head and i paid their
bills and
and they kind of i kind of set them up
and i told them like this is an
opportunity for you to get your life
stable so you can support yourself and
then you can go your way and i won't
continue to support you i'm just kind of
helping giving you a helping hand out
and that made perfect sense to me at the
time but now what i've seen
is it almost like i enabled their
not i don't want to judge it and say bad
behavior but
i i enabled their self-destruction
because they didn't really kind of do
the right thing they didn't really get a
job and continue with it
they kind of in some cases start
continue to use their drug
without letting me know they they
relapse or whatever and
then the job somehow fell away and and
things just fell apart in their lives
and i felt like my
financial support almost
contributed to their self-destruction
because it became easy oh mark's just
going to give me this he's going to give
me that he'll take care of me so i don't
have to do it myself
in your case i haven't really given you
anything i pay you for the interviews
but i didn't buy you a car i didn't buy
you
an apartment i didn't pay your groceries
i didn't i didn't
pay for this that any other you know
your kids or anything like that
and you've done this 100 by yourself
which i believe is the secret
because right now the reason you're
smiling so easily
and the really the reason you're sitting
up straight and able to smile and
feeling so good not depressed is because
you did this yourself
you believe you earned it and that's the
key to it
you know mark didn't mark didn't give
you a bunch of money to make your life
better
you did it 100 by yourself and i think
that is so much more valuable so much
more effective
than having some you know somebody
supporting you and making it easy for
you
you've earned it yeah
oh trust me there were times yeah i know
no i know but you never you never called
me once to say hey can i have money like
i get
i couldn't do it i get 100 i get 100
text messages a day
asking me for this that and the other
and you never did it once i couldn't do
it
so so the tattoos that are on your
side of your face and neck tell me about
those
uh this is a pimp and this is this one
this is my daughter's name so the pimps
will will put
their tat their name on your face
well i would agree to it though you
agreed to it i would agree to it
what what gets a woman to agree to that
um
not having [ __ ] to live for
you do you feel like you get brainwashed
when you're when you no
i feel like i want somebody to
to give me a purpose i needed a purpose
and whatever whoever had
fascinated with the connection between a
girl and her kid
yeah who you know whoever was willing to
show me and take the time to give me a
certain purpose or task to complete
that was important or dire to
even if it's having sex with strangers
and bringing in the money
it made me feel important and
every time i would lay on my back in
them cars in them hotels
you know it was just
i got to do this for the sake of the
team where i got to do this for the
sega you know and
so
i felt like i was doing something like
some nobody else would do
for their they may
people often you know tell us like oh
you you
you can leave and there's always a
pocket
where there's space and time to to get
out
you know whether we're at the store or
the mall you can escape
oh yeah it's easy um but
the longer you're there the more numb
you are most definitely
you know
you know and then what happens to your
heart and your head
as that time goes on piece by piece is
just
it's chipped away
it's chipped away to where when you get
back
to wherever you're going with you know
daddy
it starts to feel more like home
it's normal it's okay it's okay you know
and you get it's like brainwashing
i heard one of the girls that that i
know very well kind of like you but but
i
was talking with her we're shooting
another video
with her and i was i was just talking
with her in the car and
and we were kind of talking about this
and she said that like what's the
attraction to having
a dude that does this for you and she
said
like it's like it was a fact just like
you understand that
that the man is higher value than the
woman in our culture
and i'm like what like you know for my
culture that's not the case
i don't believe that men are higher
valued than women i i think we're equal
but she said it like it was just like
like saying a man is taller than a woman
she said like
the man is of higher value than a woman
and it's like so we need to get out of
here like water
yeah yeah yeah and that's
strangely just how it goes i don't know
i think a lot of people don't understand
the culture
so they look at this like this is crazy
why would you i
i should i should be held higher that's
the point
right if i'm out here doing this stuff
yeah absolutely
um so you can kick your feet up and tell
me
what else to do next then
i'm the prize you're the president you
know um
i don't know when it happened
pimping and holding i don't know when it
happened to where
um the men just
got to be the ruler yeah i don't know
it's like the women are all brainwashed
yeah i ain't no expert on the game
but it's
all you need is
a confident man
confident but weak um
and a vulnerable a vulnerable girl
who don't know herself if anything it's
easy
it's easy yeah i could do it i could be
a pimp
of course no in my culture
the man is basically the provider and
the supporter you know he brings home
the bacon and
the woman kind of and you know and this
there's a million exceptions to this so
i'm not saying this is the way it should
be
but it basically the man is the provider
and the woman
helps with the family and home and all
that kind of stuff yeah
that's how i was raised too but in in
your life or
your past life it was like you were the
provider you brought home the money
and you did all the work and you took
all the risks
expose yourself to danger and
the man just sits back and waits for you
to bring it
it's crazy
yeah you're climbing out it's insane
trust me see and you can get those
tattoos removed
yeah yeah
you're so how old are you you're young
21 21.
you're still a kid you have your whole
life ahead of you and if you make this
change now
i can guarantee you that the rest of
your life will be
so much better than if you go back
i can guarantee it not a doubt
there's not a chance that it won't
i mean look at all the destruction and
death and all the terrible stuff that
you see
in that life right you've seen it
very much there's lots of it
but it has a lot to do it's not about
common sense because what i'm doing is
saying oh it makes sense to do this it's
not about common sense it's really about
what you
believe you deserve what deep down in
your subconscious you believe you
deserve
for ivy and if that is a better life
not for your kid for you if you believe
that you deserve a better life
then that's what you'll carve out and
that's that's your actions will support
that and bring that about
but if you believe you you deserve crap
then you'll run back and start using and
you know numb the pain and
and be back to where you were a year or
two ago
so it really you know has so much to do
with your mental health
and right now it looks to me like that's
one of my biggest that's your biggest
deal yeah yeah
it's my mental that's what [ __ ] me
up it's really what [ __ ] up everybody
yeah
everybody that's what my channel is
about really it's about mental health i
think not about
drug addiction or anything else to the
point where when even if i would want to
smile
like something's just making me happy
i'm just like
dead to the world like you know like
everybody's like are you okay and i'm
like
i'm fine trust me i'm happy inside
but i'm just but um yeah
i can feel it you look different you
feel you know just your energy is
different
and this ain't even like my toe in the
water
yeah you just started so so you got here
by yourself
without any program without anything you
just did this on your own
what's more to come damn mark
i'm excited you should be i'm excited
i'm excited if this is what it feels
like just to start
i'm excited so i'm not in this
depression bubble
no more i get depressed i'm human i get
you know anxious
human but that bubble i feel like it's
kind of
pop it's popped and now i'm learning
in interaction you know and
how to still smile when you know
when i feel like smiling
yeah that'd be great for you and great
for your child
children yeah
i'm proud of you thank you such a great
story
i wish you the best of luck there and
let's talk when you get out
when you have the baby
oh garland i'm so happy
thank you mark for your support thank
you oh your best
you are the best
you